very rarely do we show up in a Super
Bowl City and talk NBA but this was the
conversation a few weeks ago when Rich
Eisen show friend of the program and
your friend from back in the day in
Syracuse tryout Dave McMenamin one of
the reporters at ESPN covering the NBA
he came on the show to walk us through
how he got the quote from LeBron about
how it would be amazing if Anthony Davis
could be a teammate which is as you know
not kosher to say that sort of thing if
you're in management but he's a team
member and McManaman said he strolled
into the Lakers locker room while the
Brawn was doing some what's he said he
was getting stretched or he's working
out on the floor of the locker room or
something and he looked up at the screen
they were watching ESPN at the time and
it was a off-camera
saying something along the lines of
Anthony Davis playing for the Lakers or
whatever and he said LeBron turned to
him and said do you know something I
don't and he goes I have no idea India's
basically said well that would be
amazing and then proceeded to opine a
little bit more about how great Anthony
Davis's and McMenamin said he asked
LeBron hey can I take that as an
on-the-record remark in the Bron knowing
at that point in time without it means
it's short now LeBrons agent rich Paul
happens to be Anthony Davis's agent and
at the time we had Chris Mannix on the
show in studio a few weeks later and he
pointed out keep an eye on the trade
deadline because the Celtics due to some
rule that Chris is about to explain to
us again if you're unfamiliar Celtics
can't trade for Anthony Davis now but
could do it in the summer can't do it
now so the question is is rich Paul the
agent of Anthony Davis coming out and
telling Adrian Warren our house key of
ESPN telling whoa hey not only is he not
gonna sign here again with New Orleans
but we've demanded a trade is he doing
that now to put the Lakers in a better
pole position for Anthony Davis
so I'm like okay we're here in Atlanta
at Super Bowl 53 week we're gonna be
talking about this all week but let's
get Chris Mannix back on the phone here
and the NBA insider Chris Mannix from
Yahoo Sports is back here on the what is
it sports ok Sports Illustrated back
here on the program how are you Chris
I'm good did I set that up um did I set
that up appropriately did I miss
anything right there Chris no I don't
think you missed anything look the the
bottom line with all this just to
explain the rule for Boston to blow it
down pretty simply contractually about
per the collective bargaining agreement
the Celtics can't have Kyrie Irving and
Anthony Davis on the roster there's just
a rule in place that says those two guys
because of the type of contracts they
have you can't have two of those types
of contracts on the roster so the
Celtics with Kyrie Irving opting out the
end of the year won't have that problem
they do have that problem so if they
want to keep Kyrie and Davis they can't
make a move like that now this
announcement by rich Paul this is all up
driven towards getting a deal done with
the Lakers because it's very clear
inside Anthony Davis's camp that they
want him with LA and they want him
playing with LeBron and they know that
if Boston's allowed to get involved this
summer
the Celtics can blow any offer from the
Lakers out of the water it's as simple
as that they have more assets that gets
better players they've got better draft
picks they've got a Memphis pick Richard
Memphis right now is in the process of
like their 14th self-destruction
you know since their incarnation the
Memphis pick is top eight protected this
year top six protected next year and
unprotected in 2021 so Boston can also
offer a potentially unprotected 20 21
pick from a bad team in a deal with the
Anthony Davis so the Laker this is all
designed but the Lakers get a
opportunity before the souks can get in
the mix to convince the Warrens to make
a deal because I mean by opening the
kimono like this Chris I mean I imagine
an Anthony
davus it's not gonna go very smooth in
the Smoothie King arena right when he
strolls back out there again in New
Orleans this this is know it it's gonna
be look it could get pretty ugly over
the next few months of Anthony Davis
stays with the pelicans that's why to a
degree it surprised me because I know
Anthony Davis cares about his image this
is the first time that he's ever made
any kind of even hint at wanting out of
New Orleans and it could get pretty bad
for him there I mean look he could have
waited till the offseason and simply
declined the contract extension offer
that has the same impact as a trade
demand because if Anthony Davis says no
I'm not going to sign your long-term
extension the pelicans would have no
other choice
in a way Davis could save some face fare
but it's clear that whether it's him or
it's rich Paul is an emphasis on getting
him to LA sooner rather than later now
all that being said it would be the
equivalent of executive malpractice for
the pelicans to make a deal right now
before the trade deadline
Boston's out there and Boston get throat
Jason Tate a movie the best player in
any package they can throw multiple
graphics they can make you the best type
of offer and this deal rich this is
personal Walker this is going to be in
my opinion the biggest deal with NBA
history you've got in there his prime
superstar we've got maybe 10 years left
of being at the highest level this is
the type of deal that's gonna make or
break the future of your franchise and
it would be lunacy for the pelicans to
make a deal like this before Boston get
involved and you know so all I have to
do is just hold on for dear life for
what two and a half months unless New
Orleans somehow amidst all this makes a
playoff race right so they just
basically have to hold on for two and a
half months because what what sort of
package could the Lakers even put
together certainly with everybody all
banged up lonzo's out for a long time
Koosman didn't even play last night so I
mean even in the short term how could
they come up with something that would
be something for Dell Demps the general
manager to say
yes - the Lakers could certainly offer a
good package and then nobody's
off-limits in LA it's cooler it's Ingram
its ball it's their number one pick and
multiple traffic Sivan down the line but
it doesn't matter it you know if Boston
if awesome wants to get into the mix
look at all they have
they've got Tatum they've got ground
they've got Marcus smart and they've got
all these drastic I mean it probably
won't shake out this way but they could
have as many as fourth round picks in
this upcoming draft I mean it just it
makes zero sense not to mention who
knows if there's a mystery team out
there who knows it's a mystery couple
get the number one pick in the draft and
all of a sudden yeah New Orleans is so
hell-bent on getting sion Williamson to
rebuild their franchise around it just
doesn't make any sense it's gonna be
tough but you know what's that old line
close your eyes and think of England
like that's what the pelicans have to do
over the next few months Chris Mannix is
Sports Illustrated a couple more minutes
left with him here on the hot story in
the NBA on this Monday in Atlanta Super
Bowl week on the Rich Eisen show alright
so again Dave McMenamin came on my show
and walked me through how that famed
LeBron that would be amazing quote came
about about being a teammate with
Anthony Davis and how it was something
that was completely off the cuff but he
agreed to say go run with it as a quote
now that said this does reek of an agent
sitting down star player who does love
the city in which he plays and does have
some form of sensitivity towards the
fans and wants to in fact have
sensitivity about the way he's viewed it
does reek of an agent saying you want to
get to LA this is the way it's got to be
played you got to be the villain just
ride it out let me handle this and how
does all of this not to go all 2011 on
you with New Orleans and the Lakers how
does this not rise to the level of Adam
Silver
being away in on this whole thing Chris
no I don't I don't think it's it's an
NBA problem and I don't look this was I
can tell you that the pelicans were
surprised the people I talk to you this
morning by the timing of all this but
they knew this was coming I mean this
was kind of the the grenade in the room
that was going to go off at some point
they've been preparing for this moment
for a long time and they're gonna get
rich offers back in returns it's going
to be incumbent on them to make the best
decision for the future of their
franchise because quite frankly the
future of the franchise could be at
stake here miss has always been a team
that's trying to be the Seattle pelicans
or the Las Vegas pelicans at some point
in the future they're not a big draw in
New Orleans there's certainly a second
or a third class citizen down there in
terms of sports fandom well behind the
Saints that's for sure so I don't think
the NBA I don't think it rises to them
getting involved I point this out to
rich you know Kyrie Irving hasn't said
anything publicly about Anthony Davis
but Kyrie Irving is they get close to
Anthony Davis and LeBron is those who
are very very tight that's why I don't
think rich Paul could scare off Boston
because Boston's got the Batphone I mean
they've got the back channel if they
want to use it to be able to interpret
what what exactly Anthony Davis is
thinking about the long-term future of
the south is his relationship with Kyrie
Irving council is rock-solid
but for him then to open this up so
publicly now as you point out makes no
sense if if going to Boston was maybe
the end game right or a potential entry
meant that that that Davis wouldn't
enjoy doing them why make them public
enemy number one potentially over the
next two and a half months before riding
that out that that doesn't make much
sense there's no question that the
Lakers right now are the preferred
choice but the question is will he stay
with Boston if he's traded there and I
think that's still very much an open
question to the point where I think boss
is pretty confident they can keep him if
they can cut a deal with the Worland so
yeah make all this up and you
you do it you I don't what the word is
but you don't give your agent permission
to do all this and it's obvious you want
to make a deal with the Lakers but if it
gets to July I don't think the Lakers
are the only team the Anthony Davis will
commit to well I guess then my last
question for you Chris Mannix is how
does it play out give me your best guess
crystal ball for me here I think it goes
past the February trade deadline and we
get a deal in the summer now no
executives I talked to across the league
there of mixed opinions with all this
but I would say this if you're I mean
forget Dell Demps the TM of the pelicans
here if you're mickey loomis who carries
a lot of clout within that organization
you I don't think you can let Dell Demps
make this decision there's a pretty good
chance they clean house entirely at the
end of this season from the general
managers box where there's been some
questions there for a long time to the
coaching staff if you're gonna do that
don't you want the guy you're hiring to
be the architect of your team's future
to be the one to pull the trigger on
Anthony Davis trade because that guy is
going to have a clearer sense of how he
wants to build a team whether it's
through maybe more established players
like the Lakers could have or a wealth
of draft picks like the Celtics might be
offering I just think this has got to
rise to an ownership level over the next
two weeks and they have got to hold off
because look there's no there's no way
the Lakers offer gets worse in a few
months there is you know obviously a big
chance missed out on another big offer
do the deal before February 7 all right
Chris thanks very much always appreciate
your your chiming in
thanks man we'll chat down the line I'm
sure hey you bet that's a Chris Mannix
of Sports Illustrated @si Chris Mannix
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience